This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The greatest mode of transportation is the finicular, which is a special kind of train pulled by a cable that runs up steep slopes. But, you know, trains are great even when they're not going up treacherous terrain. I was in Union Station in Denver recently. This is one of the stops in the California's effort, which runs from Chicago to Emeryville, California. And I firmly believe if we introduced more beautiful stations to enhance the romance and more lines to enhance the utility of trains, they could become a key part of our infrastructure again here in the US, like they are in so many other countries. My colleague, Kurt Coleststedt, is also into trains,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。最伟大的交通方式是缆车，这是一种特殊的火车，由缆绳牵引，在陡峭的斜坡上运行。但是，你知道，即使火车不在险峻的地形上行驶，它们也很棒。我最近在丹佛的联合车站。这是加州微风号列车的停靠站之一，该列车往返于芝加哥和加利福尼亚州的埃默里维尔之间。我坚信，如果我们引入更多美丽的车站来增强浪漫感，并增加更多线路来提高火车的实用性，它们就能像在其他许多国家一样，再次成为我们美国基础设施的关键部分。我的同事库尔特·科尔斯泰德也喜欢火车，
so today he and I are going to talk about some of the most ambitious, fascinating, and downright crazy train designs the world has ever seen. That's right, Roman. Today we're talking about trains, only trains, and nothing but trains. All right, then. All aboard.
所以今天我和他要聊聊世界上出现过的一些最雄心勃勃、最迷人、甚至可以说是疯狂的火车设计。没错，罗曼。今天我们只谈火车，除了火车什么都不谈。好吧，那么。请上车。
RADING'S PASSENTERS, THIS IS YOUR CONDUCTOR'S SPEAKING. them all aboard. Greetings, passengers. This is your conductor speaking. Our first stop today is Crush, Texas. Crush, Texas. Back in the late 1800s, most of the land in Texas was pretty sparsely populated, so this huge state had vast stretches that were home to less than five people per square mile. And so trains were critical infrastructure enabling some level of connectivity in these remote places. I mean, even now, I think of a lot of Texas as being pretty thinly populated. So like, I sure I can imagine it was much less populated way back one. Right. So now picture this. way back one. Right, so now picture this. One day in 1896, a town sprouted into existence and a remote part of this wide open state, but it was only temporary. For that day and
乘客们，我是你们的列车长。请上车。各位乘客，我是你们的列车长。我们今天的第一站是德克萨斯州的克拉什。克拉什，德克萨斯州。回到19世纪末，德克萨斯州的大部分土地人口相当稀少，所以这个巨大的州有大片地区每平方英里居住的人口不到五人。因此，火车是关键的基础设施，在这些偏远地区实现了某种程度的连通性。我的意思是，即使是现在，我认为德克萨斯州的许多地方人口也相当稀少。所以，我当然可以想象在很久以前，那里的人口要少得多。没错。那么现在想象一下。很久以前。没错，现在想象一下。1896年的一天，在这个广阔的州的一个偏远地区，一个城镇突然出现，但它只是暂时的。在那一天，
that day only it boasted the highest population of any city in Texas. And it was created by a regional rail company designed around a single event in which two trains would be rammed into each other at speed on purpose in front of tens of thousands of spectators. So let me ask you, of course the person to begin with, why did they want to crash two trains into each other other than that would be really, really cool? I mean, that's the main reason, right? Um, the place was called Crush, not because they were going to crush two trains together,
也仅仅在那一天，它拥有德克萨斯州所有城市中最高的人口。它是由一家区域铁路公司创建的，围绕着一个单一的事件设计，即两列火车在数万名观众面前被故意高速撞向对方。所以让我问你，当然要从头开始问，为什么他们想让两列火车相撞，除了这看起来会非常非常酷之外？我的意思是，这是主要原因，对吧？嗯，这个地方之所以叫克拉什（Crush，意为粉碎），并不是因为他们要粉碎两列火车，
as you might imagine. It was, and I swear I'm not making this up. Actually named after a guy who came up with the idea to stage the crash. A man named William George Crush. to stage the crash. A man named William George Crush. It's like his calling was written into the stars. This is kind of an amazing eponym for the ages. And after an M, as you would say. Yeah.
正如你可能想象的那样。它实际上是以一个想出这个撞车点子的人的名字命名的，我发誓我不是在编故事。一个名叫威廉·乔治·克拉什的人。想出这个撞车点子的人。一个名叫威廉·乔治·克拉什的人。这就像他的天职写在星星里一样。这是一种流传千古的绝妙同名现象。正如你会说的那样，以他的名字命名。是的。
And William Crush worked for the Missouri, Kansas, Texas railroad, or KT for short. And so Crush became the de facto name of this place that the Railroad company built to house the event. And the collision event itself came to be called the crash at Crush. The crash at Crush. Sunday Sunday Sunday. Wait, actually, what day that week was it? It was September 15th, 1896, which was actually a Tuesday. Okay, okay. Tuesday, Tuesday, Tuesday, craft at the garage. Your ticket will buy the whole seat, but you'll only need the edge. Yeah, you know, I'm not sure there was seating, but yes, you've got the right idea.
威廉·克拉什为密苏里-堪萨斯-德克萨斯铁路公司工作，简称KT。于是，克拉什成了铁路公司为举办这次活动而建造的这个地方的实际名称。而这次碰撞事件本身后来被称为“克拉什碰撞”。克拉什碰撞。周日，周日，周日。等等，实际上那天是星期几？那是1896年9月15日，实际上是一个星期二。好吧，好吧。星期二，星期二，星期二，克拉什碰撞。你的票会买下整个座位，但你只需要坐在边缘。是的，你知道，我不确定当时是否有座位，但是的，你的想法是对的。
And one of the craziest things to me is that this wasn't even the first time a railroad company had staged and publicized a crash like this. Like I can't, you know, clean to be an expert here, but I don't know of inviting people to watch trains crashing spectacularly into each other is the best way to call attention to, you know, your railroad services. You know, like, I'm sure you want people's association when train travel to be safety and comfort and convenience and things like that, not crashing. Yeah, right.
对我来说最疯狂的事情之一是，这甚至不是铁路公司第一次策划并宣传这样的撞车事故。就像我不能，你知道，自称是专家，但我不知道邀请人们观看火车壮观地撞向对方是否是引起人们关注你的铁路服务的最佳方式。你知道，就像，我肯定你希望人们对火车旅行的联想是安全、舒适、便利之类的，而不是撞车。是的，没错。
It seems like a very odd choice, but the economy at the time wasn't doing great. And so the company was open to kind of new ideas about how to make money in other ways. Plus, they had dozens of old decommissioned 50 ton locomotive engines that were basically just gathering dust. So, in part, they figured, hey, why not put these engines to some kind of good use?
这似乎是一个非常奇怪的选择，但当时的经济状况并不好。所以公司对如何以其他方式赚钱的新想法持开放态度。此外，他们有几十台旧的、退役的50吨重的火车头，基本上只是在积灰。所以，在某种程度上，他们想，嘿，为什么不把这些引擎好好利用一下呢？
So, it really is like a demolitioned RV. They're using old vehicles that they don't really care about. And except for, you know, unlike a demolitioned RV, there's only two vehicles competing and everyone crashes and everyone loses. Yeah, right. Everybody except the railroad company, assuming they can turn a profit. And they kind of cleverly decided to make attendance itself free, but people would still have to pay about $100 round trip in today's money to get two and from crush. And of course, their trains were the best way to get there.
所以，这真的就像拆除房车一样。他们使用他们并不真正在意的旧车辆。除了，你知道，与拆除房车不同的是，只有两辆车在竞争，每个人都撞车，每个人都输了。是的，没错。除了铁路公司，假设他们能盈利。他们聪明地决定让入场本身免费，但人们仍然需要支付相当于今天约100美元的往返费用才能往返于克拉什。当然，他们的火车是到达那里的最佳方式。
And yeah, right, I see. And probably the only way to get there for most people because it's this remote location inside of rural Texas. Yeah, this remote spot about 15 miles north of Waco where there was no town, no infrastructure, no anything really. And so they picked it apart because it was so remote and undeveloped, plus this particular spot formed to kind of natural amphitheater. So they just led people out in the middle of nowhere Texas, like some kind of turn of
是的，没错，我明白了。而且对于大多数人来说，这可能是到达那里的唯一方式，因为它位于德克萨斯州农村的一个偏远位置。是的，这个偏远的地方在韦科以北约15英里处，那里没有城镇，没有基础设施，真的什么都没有。所以他们选择它是因为它如此偏远且未开发，加上这个特定的地点形成了一种天然的圆形剧场。所以他们只是把人们带到德克萨斯州荒无人烟的地方，就像某种20世纪初的火人节。这是你的廉价三明治和床垫。好吧，不，谢天谢地，他们在接待方面准备得稍微好一点。他们钻了井，建了一个火车站，铺设了临时轨道来运送人们，他们提供了食物，还雇了几百名警察来维持秩序。所有这些都是在预期可能有25,000人会到场的情况下完成的，这已经很多了。但最终估计有40,000人左右参加了这次活动。哇。好吧，所以我完全能看出这作为一场奇观的吸引力。但是，你知道，我必须问，这实际上安全吗？
the 20th century fire fest. Here's your cheesy sandwich and a mattress. Well, no, thankfully they were somewhat better prepared on the hospitality front. They drilled wells and they built a train station and laid down temporary tracks to bring in people and they catered food and they hired like a couple hundred cops to keep the piece. And all of this was done with the expectation that maybe like 25,000 people would show up, which is a lot. But in the end an estimated 40,000 or so actually made it to the event. Wow. Okay, so I can totally see the appeal of this as a spectacle. But, you know, I have to to ask like what was it actually safe?
我的意思是，你知道，把观众安置在相撞的火车旁边似乎不仅仅是有点兴趣。是的，所以事实证明简短的回答是，不，它不安全。他们有工程师说它是安全的，只要人们站得足够远，但最终它非常非常危险。所以我，好吧，我几乎不敢知道，但最终，克拉什碰撞到底是怎么发生的？一切都按计划开始。火车被小心地带到一起，
I mean, you know, it's situating an audience next to crashing trains seems more than a little bit of interest. Yeah, so turns out the short answer is no, it was not safe. They had engineers saying it was safe, at least as long as people stayed far enough back, but ultimately it was very, very dangerous. So I'm, well, I'm almost afraid to find out, but in the end, how did Crash at Crush actually go down? It all started as planned. The trains were carefully brought together
在中间相遇，制造一种拍照的机会，对吧？然后它们被倒回几英里到它们的起点。没错，然后它们被倒回几英里到它们的起点。然后它们被挂上档，操作员跳下车。那部分进行得很顺利。每个人都安全下车，火车达到了它们的目标速度，大约是每小时45英里。但在撞击点，事情真的脱轨了，因为两列火车的
to meet in the middle to make kind of a photo op, right? And then they were backed up a couple of miles to their starting points. right, and then they were backed up a couple of miles to their starting points. And then they were kicked in the gear and the operators hop up. That part went fine. Everybody got off safely and the trains got up to their target speeds, which was around 45 miles per hour. But the point of impact, things literally went off the rails because both of the trains
锅炉都爆炸了。当它们爆炸时，大块的金属和碎片被炸向空中，开始像雨点般落在人群中。三个人被杀。而一位来自韦科的摄影师，顺便说一句，他拍到了一些非常棒的照片，失去了一只眼睛。天哪。
boilers exploded. And when they did, big chunks of metal and what were blasted up into the air began ringing down on the crowd. Three people were killed. And a photographer from Waco who incidentally got some really great pictures. Uh, lost an eye. Oh my God.
我的意思是，我知道那时候时代不同了，也许安全标准也不同了，但人们只是没有预见到这一点，还是不在乎？他们真的相信他们已经采取了安全预防措施来使它奏效。比如火车车厢都紧紧地锁在一起，观众被指示站在500英尺左右远的地方。最终，没有人预料到那些锅炉会爆炸。而且有那么大的人群，我想也会有很多恐慌。不仅仅是人们被碎片击中而死。哦，是的。至少起初有很多混乱。人们在奔跑、尖叫，做着你所期望的一切，
I mean, I know times were different then and maybe safety standards were different then, but did people just not see this coming or didn't care? They really believe they'd taken safety precautions to make it work. Like the train cars were all tightly chained together, and spectators were instructed to stand 500 feet or so away. In the end, no one expected those boilers to blow. And with that huge a crowd, I would imagine there was like a lot of panic as well. It wasn't just people being killed by debris. Oh, yeah. There was a lot of chaos at least at first. And people were running away and screaming and doing everything
但疯狂的是，当尘埃落定时，他们实际上开始跑回残骸处去抢纪念品，拍照之类的。但是那些被碎片伤害甚至杀害的人呢，他们发生了什么？好吧，最终铁路公司用现金补偿了他们和他们的家人。
you'd expect. But wildly enough, as the dust settled, they actually started running back towards the wreck to grab souvenirs and like take photos and things. But what about the people who are injured or even killed by debris, like what happened with them? Well, eventually the railroad compensated them and their families with a combination of cash.
再说一次，我不是在编故事，还有终身火车票，我不知道，这看起来有点迟钝。是的。是的。我想是这样。但是，我知道发生了一些可怕的事情，但当时它被视为一场灾难吗？比如，你知道，那个有计划的人，像克拉什先生，他们是否让他为这场可怕的悲剧负责，这场悲剧为了奇观而伤害和杀害了人们？好吧，铁路公司基本上当场解雇了他，
And again, I'm not making this up lifetime train tickets, which I don't know, just seems kind of tone deaf. Yeah. Yeah. I guess. But like, I know something horrible happened, but was it viewed at the time as a catastrophe? Like, you know, did the man with the plan, like Mr. Crush, did they hold him accountable for this horrific tragedy that maimed and killed people for the, you know, just for the sake of spectacle? Well, the railroad company fired him basically
但随后他们转过身，一天后又重新雇用了他，因为媒体报道实际上并不那么糟糕。总的来说，很多报道似乎相当正面。所以尽管这次活动产生了悲惨的后果，但克拉什碰撞最终还是一个相当不错的营销活动。哇。我想这就是他们所说的。没有坏的宣传，对吧？
on the spot, but then they turned around and rehired him a day later because the media coverage wasn't actually that bad. A lot of it seemed pretty positive overall. And so despite the tragic consequences of this event, the crash at Crush turned out to be a pretty good marketing campaign after all. Wow. I guess that's what they say. There's no such thing as bad press, huh?
在这种情况下令人沮丧。但是，是的，是真的。果然，这甚至不是同类事件中的最后一次。在接下来的几十年里，在全国各地的嘉年华和州博览会上都能看到火车相撞。而克拉什本身就是一个轰动事件，它甚至激励了拉格泰姆之王，
Depressing in this case. But yeah, true. And sure enough, that wasn't even the last event of its kind. For decades to come, crashing trains could be found at carnivals and state fairs across the country. And Crush itself was such a sensation that it even inspired the King of Ragtime,
斯科特·乔普林，写了一首关于它的歌，《伟大的克拉什碰撞进行曲》。好吧，那是一首快乐的小曲子，也许比我从一个由撞车事故激发的作品中预期的要轻快一些。是的，我不确定这是因为在这种情况下它的演奏方式，还是仅仅是我们现代人的耳朵听起来如此，但他确实在作曲中为其他能演奏这首曲子的音乐家做了这些注释，明确告诉他们如何用音乐复制火车相撞的声音。今天，克拉什的临时城镇早已不复存在，但火车迷们仍然可以参观这个遗址并阅读附近的牌匾，它是献给克拉什碰撞的。
Scott Chaplin, to write a song about it, the Great Crush Collision March. Well, that is a jolly little tune, maybe a little bit more upbeat than I was expecting from something inspired by a crash. Yeah, and I'm not sure if it's the way that it's being played in this case or just horror modern ears here, but he did make these notes in the composition for other musicians who could play this, specifically telling them how to replicate crashing train sounds with music. Today, the temporary town of Crush is long gone, but train nerds can still visit the site and read a nearby plaque, which is dedicated to the Crushite Crush.
一定要读牌匾。下一站，意大利罗马。这个车站仍在建设中，所以下车时请注意脚下。当你想到罗马时，你可能会想到著名的古代建筑和遗迹，比如斗兽场、万神殿、罗马广场之类的东西。没错，没错。当然。但这只是冰山一角。整个罗马城都是历史文物和建筑的宝库，
Always read the plaque. Next stop, Rome, Italy. This station is still under construction, so watch your step as you exit. When you think of Rome, you probably think of famous ancient buildings and ruins, like the Colosseum, the Pantheon, the Roman Forum, things like that. Right, right. Of course. But that's just the tip of the iceberg. The whole city of Rome is a treasure trove of historical artifacts and architecture,
而游客只能看到其中的一部分，因为大部分仍然埋在地下。但是所有这些需要发掘的奇妙的地下历史层，确实让致力于扩大城市地铁网络的城市规划者感到困难。我的意思是，这听起来确实像一场噩梦。就像他们在挖掘时，必须一直遇到文物。是的，他们确实会，特别是在靠近地表的地方。一旦他们到达线路实际运行的深度，水平挖掘往往不是什么大问题，但到达那里，
and tourists only see some of that, because so much of it is still buried below the surface. But all of these wonderful subterranean layers of history to be uncovered have really made it hard for urban planners who are working to expand the city's metro network. I mean, it really does sound like a nightmare. Like as they tunnel, they must run into artifacts all the time. Yeah, they do, especially near the surface. Once they get down to the depth where the lines actually run, tunneling horizontally tends to not be a big issue, but getting down
并建造车站、通风设施以及所有其他近地表基础设施。那是他们遇到真正问题的地方。是的。那么他们是如何绕过它的呢？比如所有那些靠近地表的历史层？通常，他们不能。这些挖掘几乎总是变成考古发掘。并且至少在一个案例中，
there and building out the stations and ventilation and all that other near-service infrastructure. That's where they have real problems. Yeah. So how do they get around it? Like all those layers of history that are near the surface? Often, they can't. And these excavations almost invariably become archeological digs. And in at least one case,
城市完全放弃了一个计划中的车站，出于保护原因。那么接下来会发生什么呢？比如，你只是在别处挖掘并再试一次吗？有时，是的。结果，这些看起来本来很直接的基础设施项目往往变成了长达数十年的努力。他们甚至雇佣了经过特别认证的建筑工人，他们受过培训，可以兼任考古学家，以确保当他们遇到文物时，一切都能得到妥善处理。我发现了一些戒指，我发现了一些玻璃器皿，
the city abandoned a plant station entirely for preservation reasons. And so what happens then? Like, do you just dig somewhere else and try again? Sometimes, yeah. And as a result, these, you know, otherwise seemingly straightforward infrastructure projects often turn into these decades-long endeavors. And they even employ especially certified construction workers who are trained to double as archaeologists to make sure that when they encounter artifacts, everything gets handled properly. I found some bullbrings, I found glassware,
镀金的，描绘了一个罗马神，一些双耳瓶。有时他们会遇到真正不可思议的东西。比如，不久前，他们发现了一个可以追溯到公元二世纪的完整建筑群。它充满了大理石地板、装饰性马赛克、彩绘壁画，应有尽有，而且大部分都出奇地完好无损。他们应该把它变成一个火车站。哦，那会很棒，是的。所以我看到你有两股相互竞争的力量，你知道，我完全支持这两个阵营。
glaminated in gold, depicting a Roman god, some amphory. And sometimes they encounter truly incredible things. Like, not too long ago, they found a whole building complex dating back to the second century. And it was filled with marble floors, ornamental mosaics, painted frescoes, the works, and most of it was surprisingly intact. They should have turned it into a train station. Oh, that would have been great, yeah. So I see that you have two competing forces that are, you know, I'm fully in both camps.
比如我希望这些考古发掘得到保护。我也希望，你知道，功能性的基础设施和地铁线路。这听起来对所有相关人员来说都是一种头痛。是的，确实可能是。但有一个一线希望，因为如果不是因为城市推动扩大公共交通，许多这些遗址根本就不会被挖掘。所以从某种意义上说，历史学家确实受益于发掘出各种可能本来会无限期埋藏的东西。嗯，在一些车站，他们在车站建设过程中发现的古代文物是
Like I want these archaeological digs preserved. I also want, you know, functional infrastructure and metro lines. It just sounds like a headache for everyone involved. Yeah, it really can be. But there's a silver lining because a lot of these sites wouldn't be excavated at all if it weren't for the cities pushed to expand public transit So in a way historians do benefit from uncovering all kinds of stuff that might otherwise have just stayed buried indefinitely Hmm and in some stations ancient Alex that they find during the construction of the stations are
在这些展示柜中可见的，这使得游客可以接触到它们，对于日常通勤者来说也是一件很整洁的事情。哦，那很好。我喜欢那样。你可以去某个地方的火车站，看到一个小博物馆，展示在那个遗址发现的东西。那很酷。是的。各位乘客请注意！餐车现已开始提供餐饮服务。作为一种建筑类型，餐车非常引人注目，长而薄，带有镀铬装饰和圆角。在它们狭窄的空间内，只有足够的空间走过并坐下。
Visible in these display cases which makes them accessible to tourists and also just kind of a neat thing for everyday commuters. Oh, that's nice. I like that. That you could go to a train station somewhere and see a little museum of what was found in that site. That's cool. Yeah. Attention passengers! Food service has now begun in the dining car. As a building-type diner are striking, the long and thin with chrome accents and rounded corners. Inside their narrow spaces, there's just enough room to walk through and sit down.
在一个由石头、砖块、钢铁和玻璃制成的更高、更深的建筑世界里，餐车有点奇怪，但如果你了解它们来自哪里，它们所有奇特的设计特征突然就变得更有意义了。餐车是餐车的演变，你知道火车上的那种。不仅仅是它们的名字和美学可以追溯到铁路。许多餐车是作为模块化单元预制的，专门设计用于通过卡车或火车运送到最终目的地，因此有了长而窄的布局。企业家杰里·奥马奥尼被广泛认为是餐车的创造者，
In a built world of taller and deeper structures made with stone and brick and steel and glass, diners are kind of strange, but if you understand where they come from, all their curious design features suddenly make a lot more sense. Diners are an evolution of dining cars, you know the ones found on trains. It's not just their name and aesthetic that traces back to railways. Many diners were prefabricated as modular units and specifically designed to be taken by truck or train to their final destination, hence the long and narrow layout. Entrepreneur Jerry O'Mahoney is widely credited with coming up with the diner as it is and
并在1913年建造了第一个。他的作品演变成了现在独特的餐车外观，长而窄，光滑且弯曲，带有闪亮的镀铬装饰。许多复古的预制餐车配备了柜台、凳子、瓷砖地板，甚至洗手间，它们只是被运送到目的地，然后连接到现场的公用设施上。在某些情况下，实际的餐车也被改造成独立的餐车。
building the first one in 1913. His creations evolved to have that now distinctive diner look, long and narrow sleek and curvy with flashy chrome accents. Many vintage pre-fab diners came complete with counters, stools, tile floors, even restrooms, and they were just transported to the destination and they got hooked up to on-site utilities. In some cases, actual dining cars were also converted into free-standing diners.
而在其他情况下，餐车只是为了那种怀旧的吸引力而被制作成看起来像经典的预制件，顺便说一句，这对我完全有效。下一站，泰国曼谷。由于行人活动异常频繁，火车在接近该车站时将减速。感谢您的耐心等待。泰国曼谷最大的鱼市场之一实际上被一条火车轨道一分为二。因此，摊贩们排列在铁路线两侧，这个地方的名字翻译过来就是“雨伞收起市场”。好吧，你要向我解释那个名字，因为那
And in other cases, diners are simply made to look like classic prefamps for that nostalgic appeal, which, by the way, totally works on me. Next stop, Bangkok Thailand. The train will be slowing down on approach to this station due to unusually high pedestrian activity. We appreciate your patience. One of the largest fish markets in Bangkok, Thailand, is effectively bisected by a train track. And so, vendors flank the rail line, and the name of the place translates to umbrella pull down market. Okay, you're going to explain that name to me, because that doesn't
根本说不通。没错，这是一个非常奇怪的名字，但它指的是这个非常特定的特征，或者可以说是塑造这个市场运作方式的根本缺陷。因为我提到的那些摊贩，他们不仅仅是在轨道两侧像退后一点那样。他们把货物直接摆在铁轨旁边。所以购物者实际上必须走在火车经过的铁轨之间。市场本身已经有一百多年的历史了。当它在1905年左右第一次被放在那里时，没有铁轨。那是后来才有的。但即使在它被铁轨一分为二之后，
make any sense. Right, it's a very strange name, but it refers to this very specific feature or arguably bug that fundamentally shapes how this market works. Because those vendors I mentioned, they're not just on either side of the tracks like set back aways. They set up their goods right against the rails. And so shoppers have to actually walk between the rails, where the trains go. The market itself is over a hundred years old. And when it was first put there in like 1905, there was no railroad track. That came later. But even once it was cut in half by a railroad track,
人们仍然不断地来买鱼，买农产品。这是它在实践中如何展开的一个片段。当火车接近时，警报声响起，以便人们知道要避开，摊贩们迅速收回他们的商品，他们抬起遮阳篷，以确保他们不会被火车撞到。
people just kept coming to get their fish, to get their produce. And here's a clip of how it actually unfolds in practice. When a train approaches a alarm sound so that people know to get out of the way and vendors quickly pull back their wares and they lift up their awnings to make sure that they don't get hit by the train.
因此得名“雨伞收起市场”。哇，你没开玩笑。那些火车几乎直接擦过遮阳篷。即使在它们被收回之后。我的意思是，这个系统，它看起来有点棒。这是一种在拥挤的城市环境中最大化空间的创造性方式，但它看起来也极其危险。是的，在某种程度上，它确实非常危险。
Hence the umbrella pull down more. Wow, you weren't kidding. Those trains are almost brushed right against the Onyx. Even after they've been retracted. I mean, this system, it seems like you're kind of awesome. It's a creative way to maximize space and a crowded urban setting, but it also seems incredibly dangerous. Yeah, and to some extent, it is really dangerous.
但显然事故相对较少且相隔很远。大多数时候，它们只是涉及火车撞到某人的商品，比如我离轨道太近了，或者一张没有被收回足够远或足够快的桌子。不过，一些摊贩有这些特别聪明的解决方案，比如安装在他们在路面上创造的小轨道上的轮式推车，这样他们就可以根据需要将它们来回滑离铁轨。在路面上，这样他们就可以根据需要将它们来回滑离铁轨。如果你观察那个过渡时刻，当火车来的时候，在大多数情况下，这是一场编排得相当好的舞蹈。我的意思是，仍然，我不知道我个人是否会靠得那么近，但从
But apparently accents are relatively few in far between. And most of the time, they just involve a train hitting someone's wares, like I got left too close to the tracks, or a table that didn't get pulled back far enough or fast enough. Some vendors though have these particularly clever solutions, like wheeled carts that are set into little tracks that they've created in the pavement, so they can just slide them back and forth away from the rails as needed. in the pavement so they can just slide them back and forth away from the rails as needed. And if you watch that moment of transition, when the train is coming, it is, for the most part, a pretty well-choreographed dance. I mean, still, I don't know if I would cut it that close personally, but it is clear from
这些视频中很清楚，摊贩们知道该做什么以及什么时候做，你知道。另外，看起来火车开得很慢，而且鸣笛很多。尽管如此，他们等到最后一秒才去拿鱼，然后只是走开，这真是太疯狂了。你一定真的很想吃那条鱼。是的，是的。
these videos that the vendors know what to do and when to do it, you know. Plus, it looks like the train's going pretty slow and it honks a lot. Still, it's just wild that they wait until the very last seconds to get their fish and then just kind of step out of the way. You must really want that fish. Yes, yes.
据说鱼真的非常好。所以也许这使得风险是值得的。我不怀疑。各位乘客请注意，这列火车将绕过即将到来的车站，因为该地点的服务已永久停止。我还有另一个简短而甜蜜的故事要讲给所有的火车迷听。它是关于日本最北端的岛屿北海道的一条偏远线路。有一个农村火车站几乎完全没有被使用。到2010年代初，它只剩下一名固定的乘客。她是一名十几岁的女孩，高中二年级学生，每天往返于学校两次。
Supposedly the fish is really excellent. So maybe that makes the risk with it. I don't doubt it. Attention passengers, this train will be bypassing the upcoming stop, as service to this location has been permanently discontinued. I have another short and sweet story for all you train fans. It's about a remote line in Hokkaido, the northernmost island in Japan. There was one rural train stop that was almost entirely unused. By the early 2010s, it was down to just one single regular passenger. She was a teenager, a sophomore in high school, who wrote it twice a day to and from class.
区域铁路当局计划关闭这条线路，直到她的父母介入。当然，他们请求，车站可以保持开放，直到他们的女儿毕业。他们如愿以偿。车站确实永久关闭了，但那是在她最后一次乘车去参加高中
The regional rail authorities were planning to shut the line down into her parents intervened. Certainly they asked, the stop could stay open just until their daughter graduated. They got their wish. The stop did close permanently, but only after she took one final ride to her high school
毕业典礼之后。下一站，德国石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因地区。请注意，为了进入岛屿，乘客需要换乘火车才能到达目的地。我十几岁时住在德国，从那以后回去过好几次。所以在这两者以及该国史诗般的铁路网络之间，我有很多关于德国的火车故事也就不足为奇了。事实上，我最喜欢的全国火车线路之一就是这段连接大陆和一个叫诺德斯特兰迪施穆尔的小岛的小段轨道，
graduation ceremony. Next stop, the Schlage-Vig Holstein region of Germany. Please note that for island access, passengers will need to switch trains in order to reach their destination. I lived in Germany as a teenager, and I've been back a number of times since then. So between that and the country's epic railway network, it's probably no surprise that I have a ton of train stories about Deutschland. In fact, one of my favorite train lines in the entire country is this little stretch of track that connects the mainland with a tiny island called Nordstrondischmur,
它位于北海的海岸外。我们谈论的是一个多小的岛屿？它不到一平方英里，但由于其低洼地区经常被淹，它实际上只能维持几十名居民。当地人称这种情况为“陆地冬天”或“陆地之下”。我明白了，但我很感激你的翻译。没错，没错。我给你开个玩笑。总之，为了应对这种情况，人们住在这些四座人造山上的房子里，
which is located off the coast in the North Sea. And how tiny of an island are we talking about here? It's less than a square mile, but because it's low-lying areas flood regularly, it can only really support about a few dozen residents. And locals refer to this situation as Land Winter or Land Under. I got that one, but I appreciate you translating it. Right, right. I threw you a saw all there. Anyway, to cope with this situation, folks live in homes on these four artificial mountains,
这些山被堆高，以便它们保持在水位线以上。一条窄轨铁路是往返该岛的唯一交通工具。所以我推断窄轨铁路比普通火车轨道小一点，但你能详细说明一下吗？没错。所以基本上标准火车线路的轨道间距约为五英尺。窄轨线路通常范围从仅两到三英尺宽。所以自然地，它们更便宜，更容易制造。等等，这有点题外话，但如果它们更便宜，更容易制造，
and these mountains are built up so that they stay above the water line. And one narrow gauge rail is the only transit to and from the island. And so I gather that a narrow gauge rail is a little bit smaller than regular train tracks, but can you elaborate on that? Right. So basically a standard train line has rails that are set around five feet apart. Narrow gauge lines generally range from just two to three feet apart. So naturally they're cheaper and easier to make. Wait, this is kind of a little bit of an aside, but like if they're cheaper and easier to make,
为什么你不把所有的轨道都做得比那更窄呢？我的意思是，这看起来很合乎逻辑，对吧？但问题是窄轨线路不太稳定，不太适合现代高速列车，特别是。所以它们过去在德国确实有很多，但大多数在几十年前就关闭或升级了。但不是这一条，
why don't you just make all rails narrower than that? I mean, it seems logical, right? But the problem is that narrow gauge lines are less stable and not really suited to modern fast trains, especially. So they're used to actually be a lot of these in Germany, but most of them are shut down or upgraded decades ago. But not this one,
因为我想它服务的人口太少了。是的，是的，完全正确。所以一个有趣的事实可以让你了解这个地方的规模，据报道他们有德国最小的学校，只有三名学生。所以真的，没有多少人来来往往，对标准尺寸的火车引擎和火车车厢的需求也不大。
because it serves such a small population, I guess. Yeah, yeah, exactly. So a fun fact to give you a sense of the scale of this place, they reportedly have the smallest school in Germany with just three students. So really, there aren't that many people coming and going, and there's not a lot of demand for standard-sized train engines and train cars.
哦，所以不仅轨道更小，火车本身也像微型的一样？哦，是的。而且它们看起来通常大不相同。这是我见过的他们使用的最正常的那个。哦，我觉得它很可爱。有这个小火车引擎，它拉着一个小敞篷，就像货车车厢。它们是在运土还是什么的？我不知道，但它也很小很可爱。而且它是红绿相间的。它看起来有点像，你知道，火车绕着走，看到那些作品。
Oh, so not only are the track smaller, like the trains themselves are like miniature? Oh, yes. And they often look a lot different. Here's the most normal looking one that I've actually seen them use. Oh, I think it's adorable. There's this little train engine, it's pulling a little open top, like the cargo cars. Are they hauling dirt or something? I don't know, but it's also small and cute. And it's like red and green. It kind of looks like, you know, the train going around, seeing those works.
完全正确。而且那只是看起来比较标准的那个。几十年来，他们使用了许多不同的设计，比如风力驱动的，像带帆的，还有露天的，你只是坐在一个小捏和拖的地方。然后还有这个，这可能是我的最爱。哦哇，好吧，所以这就像一辆自行车，有旧自行车座，踩踏板
Exactly. And that's just the more standard looking one. Over the decades, they've used a bunch of different designs, like ones that were wind powered, like with sails, and open air ones where you just sit out a little pinch and tug along. And then there's this one that is probably my favorite. Oh wow, okay, so this is just like a bike, with old bike seat, pedaling
以及轨道上的一切，而不是轮子。这是否意味着每个人都有某种像这样的轨道车辆，当涉及到去大陆获取补给之类的东西时，他们可以往返？是的，岛上的每个家庭都有他们自己的小火车，原因正是如此。但还有其他几种往返的选择。当潮水高时，船可以停靠，当潮水低时，如果小心的话，人们实际上可以直接走过泥滩。但在
and everything on rails instead of wheels. Does that mean that everyone has a kind of like rail vehicle like this that they can get you know two and fro when it comes to going to the mainland in order to get supplies and stuff. Yeah, every household on the island has their own little train for exactly that reason. But there are a few other options for getting back and forth. When the tide is high, boats can dock, and when it's low, people can actually just walk right across the mud flats if they're careful about it. But at
任何时候，由于轨道被抬高在这个人造脊上，他们都可以通过火车往返。我的意思是，我仍然对人们能在这些经常被淹没的地方生活感到惊讶。是的，这很棘手，但他们让它奏效了。比如北海的岛屿主要依靠农业和旅游业的结合来生存。例如，诺德斯特兰迪施穆尔的居民饲养绵羊等。这是一个人在水低时走过去的人的片段，对居民的采访。我喜欢他们的交流的一部分是，他们两人都有这些非常独特的区域方言。采访者直接用这个非常北德的问候语开始，Moin, Moin。
any time, because of the way that rail is raised up on this artificial ridge, they can just get back and forth by train. I mean, I'm still just kind of surprised that people can make do in places like this that flood all the time. Yeah, it is tricky, but they make it work. Like islands in the North Sea mostly subsist on a combination of agriculture and tourism. And the residents of Nord-Standish were, for example, raised sheep among other things. And here's a clip from a guy who walked across when the water was low, an interview to resident. And part of what I love about their exchange is that both of them have these very distinctive regional dialects. And the interviewer launches right in with this very northern German greeting, Moin, Moin.
Moin，你好。你知道Hallig Nordstein is Moor是否是一个帮派，或者一个厨师，或者你是什么意思？是的，他将是下一个。因为我知道Hallig将是下一个。屋顶外面。他刚才提到的事情之一是他既是一名农民，
Moin, hello. Do you know if Hallig Nordstein is Moor as a Boer in the gang, or a chef, or what do you mean? Yeah, he's going to be the next one. Because I know Hallig is going to be the next one. Outdoor-of-the-roof. And one of the things he just mentioned is how he works both as a farmer,
但也有一份从事海岸保护的副业。因为在这样的地方，海平面上升正在造成损失。所以他们正在尝试不同的解决方案，在极端情况下，他们甚至可能不得不拆除整个建筑物，然后抬高它们下面的山，然后在上面重建。但有些家庭在这里生活了几代人。他们非常热衷于解决一些问题，以便他们能留在他们的祖先土地上，对吧？
but also has a side job of working on coastal protection. Because in places like this, sea level rise is taking its toll. So they're experimenting with different solutions, and in extreme cases they might even have to take entire buildings down and then raise up the mountains under them and then rebuild on top of that. But some families have lived here for generations. They're really keen on sorting something out so that they can stay on their ancestral land, right?
是的，是的。我的意思是，这听起来确实很艰难。他们能在岛上生活，所做的一切也听起来很神奇。你知道，就像，他们还能拥有一列火车。你知道，谁不想拥有自己的梦想。现在，在我们离开北海之前，我确实想再换一下轨道一分钟，因为有一个特别著名的岛屿，再往北一点，
Yeah, yeah. I mean, it does sound tough. It also sounds kind of amazing what they've been able to do, living out on this island. You know, like, and they get to own a train. You know, it doesn't want to own their own dream. Now, before we leave the North Sea, I do want to switch tracks for just one more minute, because there's this one particularly famous island, a bit farther north,
它也通过火车与大陆相连，但这实际上不是我要谈论的。我第一次听说这个地方是在90年代初，当时我是一名在德国的学生。来自我的第一盘德语磁带，是由朋克乐队D-Airstuh写的。这首歌《Vestelon》是关于这个更大、更豪华、坦率地说更著名的北海岛上的一个时髦度假小镇。所以基本上，它是对这些资产阶级度假色彩的模仿。他唱着他如何被困在柏林，所以他坐在湖边的一个手持设备上，只是希望和想象他能回到Vesterland，坐在北海边一个漂亮的
and it's also connected to the mainland by train, but that's not actually what I'm going to talk about. I first learned about this place in the early 90s when I was a student in Germany. From my first German cassette tape, which was written by the punk band, D-Airstuh. And this particular song, Vestelon, is about a fancy resort tone on this bigger and posher and frankly much more well-known North Sea Island. So basically, it's a parody of these bougie resort colors. He's singing about how he's stuck in Berlin and so he's sitting on a handheld by a lake just wishing and imagining he could be back on Vesterland instead sitting along a nice
沙滩上。und die Pizza und die Nutzung。休息后，我们今天最后一站将是岛国日本。下车时请注意铁路工人指点和呼喊。我回来和库尔特·库尔斯泰德谈论火车。哦是的，如果不提到日本，做一个关于火车的节目简直是犯罪，它在铁路方面有着非常丰富的创新历史。例如，他们有地震仪，当地震开始时会发出信号让火车停止。结果，他们基本上不再有与地震相关的火车事故了。嗯。我的意思是，在一个以地震闻名的国家，这似乎是一个至关重要的发展。
sandy beach on the North Sea. und die Pizza und die Nutzung. After the break, our final stop today will be the island nation of Japan. Please pay attention to the rail workers pointing and calling as you exit the train. I'm back with Kurt Kulstad talking about trains. Oh yes, and it would be, of course, criminal to do an episode about trains and not mentioned Japan, with its really rich history of being super innovative when it comes to railways. For example, they have seismometers that signal trains to stop when an earthquake is starting. And as a result, they have basically no train accidents related earthquakes anymore. Huh. I mean, in a country famous for earthquakes, that seems like a vital development.
哦是的，绝对。日本还刚刚推出了一种公共汽车/火车混合动力车，它有用于公路和轨道的轮子，只需15秒即可转换。哇，哦，我喜欢它。就像所有最好的公共交通工具合二为一。是的，太棒了，太甜了。但我简要谈谈的主要创新是这个叫“指差确认”的系统，
Oh yeah, definitely. And Japan also just launched a bus slash train hybrid that has wheels for both roads and rails and converts in just 15 seconds. Wow, oh, I love it. Like all the best of public transit rolled into one. Yeah, it's great, sweet. But the main innovation I wanna talk about briefly is this system called Point and Call,
这并不是关于火车本身是如何设计的，而是关于铁路员工如何保持它们的运行。这是一个展示它在实践中如何工作的片段。好吧，所以有这些响亮的公告，我当然听不懂，但真正让我跳出来的是铁路员工在做多少手势。非常戏剧化。我理解，这就是指差确认系统的重点。
which is not really about how trains themselves are designed but about how railway employees keep them running. And here's a clip showing how this works in practice. Okay, so there are these loud announcements, which of course I cannot understand, but what really jumped out at me is how much the rail employees are kind of gesticulating. It's very dramatic. I take it, this is the point of the point and call system.
但他们指的东西的实际重点是什么？没错。所以简而言之，指差确认方法旨在提高铁路线上的安全性。日本进行了广泛的行为研究来提出这个系统。通过测试，他们得出结论，如果他们的工人将一种习惯与一种以上的感官联系起来，例如，如果他们在谈论与该事物相关的动作时身体上指着一个事物，它可以显著减少工作场所的错误。好吧，所以驻扎在火车旁边的工人指着并喊出一切正常，
But what's the actual point of what they're pointing at? Right. So in short, the point and call method is meant to improve safety on rail lines. Japan did extensive behavioral research to come up with this system. Through testing, they concluded that if their workers associate a habit with more than one sense, for example, if they're physically pointing out a thing while talking about the action that they're performing related to that thing, it can reduce workplace errors dramatically. Okay, so the workers stationed alongside the train point and call out that it's all clear,
比如没有人被夹在门里。而列车长在启动前向前指，这是一种让操作更安全的戏剧性系统。是的，完全正确。而且不仅仅是方向。他们还指着按钮、仪表、标志和其他东西。每一个动作都旨在帮助所有在铁路系统工作的人更加警觉并保持专注。我的意思是，如果这工作得这么好，除了日本之外，还有其他地方吗？
like no one's caught in a door. And the conductor points forward before starting that that's a sort of like whole theatrical system of making this operation safer. Yeah, exactly. And it's not just direction. They also point at buttons and gauges and signs and other stuff. And each of these actions is designed to help everybody who's working on the rail system be moral alert and stay on task. I mean, if this works so well, is it found anywhere else besides Japan
如果其他国家采用了这个系统？你知道，它在其他国家确实没有像我在日本看到的那样流行，考虑到它在日本是多么成功，而且不完全清楚为什么，但有些地方确实使用了指差确认方法的一部分。比如他们只是指还是他们只是喊？
if other countries adopted this system? You know, it really hasn't taken off in other countries as much as I would have thought, given how successful it has been in Japan, and it's not totally clear why, but there are places that do use parts of the point and call approach. Like did they just point or they just call?
他们做什么？好吧，例如，在纽约市，大都会运输署的列车长在离开车站前必须指着一个标志，但他们不必伴随那个标志喊出公告。嗯。我的意思是，是因为他们感到如此自觉还是什么的关于喊叫的部分？
What do they do? Well, for example, in New York City, Metro Transit Authority conductors have to point at a sign before leaving a station, but they don't have to shout an announcement along with that. Huh. I mean, is it because they feel so conscious or something about the shouting part?
这让我觉得很奇怪。是的，我想也许就是那样。也许这就是为什么他们只是坚持指着。但无论如何，网上有一个非常愚蠢的视频，一群人决定通过在他们应该指的标志前面放上标志来让MTA代理人微笑，上面写着“如果你死性感就指这里”之类的短语，
It strikes me as odd. Yeah, I think maybe that's it. And maybe that's why they just stick to pointing. But in any case, there's this pretty goofy video online of a bunch of people who decided to make some MTA agents smile by putting up signs in front of the sign that they're supposed to point at, with phrases like point here if you're dead sexy
当然操作员别无选择，他们必须指。哦，那是一些非常棒的基础设施乐趣，对吧，特别是对于纽约人来说，我觉得那真的，那真的很好，哦我喜欢它，哦酷，好吧，下次我坐火车时寻找那个指点。那很酷。是的。是的。《99%隐形》本周由库尔特·科尔斯泰德和马丁·冈萨雷斯制作。
and of course operators have no choice they have to point Oh that's some pretty awesome infrastructure fun right right especially for New Yorkers I feel like that's really that's really nice oh I like it oh cool well look for the point next time I'm on a train. That's pretty cool. Yeah. Yeah. 99% invisible was produced this week by Kurt Colestead and Martin Gonzales.
当然，运营商别无选择，他们必须指出来。哦，这真是一些非常棒的基础设施乐趣，对吧？特别是对于纽约人来说，我觉得这真的非常好。哦，我喜欢它。哦，酷。好吧，下次我坐火车时会留意那个点。那真的很酷。是的。是的。《99%隐形》本周由库尔特·科尔斯特德和马丁·冈萨雷斯制作。
Chris Baroubaig was our affable conductor. Music by our director of Sound Swan Real. With additional music by Scott Jopplin and D. Ertsa. Gleiny Hall is the executive producer of the rest of the team includes Vivian Leigh, Emmett Fitzgerald, Jason Dillion, Christopher Johnson, Lashmodon, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM Podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful.
Chris Baroubaig是我们和蔼可亲的指挥。音乐由我们的声音总监Swan Real制作。额外音乐由Scott Jopplin和D. Ertsa提供。Gleiny Hall是执行制片人，团队其他成员包括Vivian Leigh、Emmett Fitzgerald、Jason Dillion、Christopher Johnson、Lashmodon、Joe Rosenberg、Sophia Klatsker以及我Roman Mars。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一员。现在总部位于北边六个街区外的Pandora大楼。非常漂亮。
Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI orc. We're on Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Greetings, passengers traveling between Sirius XM and Stitcher.
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到我们的节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorc。我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目链接以及99PI的每一期往期节目。向往返于Sirius XM和Stitcher之间的乘客问好。
Those are our stops for today, but look forward to seeing you on another 99% invisible train soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是我们今天的站点，但期待很快能在另一列99% Invisible列车上见到你。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。